they're the reigning premier league
champions and now liverpool are at the
heart of project big picture
the controversial plan to tear up and
reshape english football
manchester united's billionaire owners
the glazer family
are also driving towards what will be
the biggest shake-up of the game since
the premier league breakaway in 1992.
the proposals include the premier league
being reduced from 20 clubs to 18
and the dismantling of the league cup
and the community shield
special status will be given to the nine
longest serving clubs
and the vote of only six required to
make major changes
including the removal of the chief
executive
to sweeten the deal for lower league
clubs
million pounds would be given
immediately to the efl
as a covered pandemic bailout and 25
of future premier league revenue with
football experiencing its deepest
financial crisis in history
clubs in lower leagues are desperate for
a rescue package
government has described project big
picture as a backroom deal being cooked
up to create a closed shop
but the efl chairman is one of the
architects this is bound to be seen by
some as an attempt for the biggest
and richest clubs to exercise a land
grab
is that what's going on here no uh
you know a land grab that involves
partying with 25
of the premier league's income for the
greater good of the game is um
a pretty inept land grab um
there's no reason for them to do that
other than that it is the right thing to
do
that it secures the future of the
pyramid
parry's hopeful that the required total
of 14 top flight clubs will vote for his
plan
but the premier league as an
organisation has already voiced
opposition
in a statement they said a number of the
individual proposals in the plan
published today could have a damaging
impact on the whole game and we're
disappointed to see that rick parry
chair of the efl has given his on the
record support
a number of club executives have told me
that this proposal looks more like a
takeover than a rescue plan
to get project big picture over the line
smaller clubs have to be persuaded
that what's been drawn up isn't simply
an attempt to squeeze them out
martha kellner sky news